foreign
[Music]
what's up foreign
this is
[Music]
Christian
foreign
[Music]
hello
good evening welcome welcome the few the
proud the summer attendees at the table
you guys are wonderful my name is Karen
and I'm part of the Elder leadership
team and uh the admin assistant and
various other things here at the table
I'm also as you can see in a boot uh and
I think the number one question I've Got
Tonight is what happened
uh so really exciting story I was
literally taking something out
to the backyard to our backyard trash
can stepped off the patio onto the lawn
rolled my ankle heard a loud pop and hit
the ground
so there I am I'm in the backyard by
myself
on my back I can't move and I'm going
how am I going to get up because I was
in so much pain I'm like I can't get up
right now there's no way I'm like what
am I gonna do what
well I couldn't walk because I heard my
yeah exactly exactly but I could I
didn't even know if I could crawl at
that point because I was in so much pain
and I thought wait a minute I've got a
I've got an Apple Watch and so
like Life Alert I called my husband Gary
from my watch and I said I've fallen and
I can't get up
and he came out and he's like what is
going on
my watch is like can I help you like no
so helpful
um anyways hence the boot got it on for
a couple more weeks then hopefully I'll
be
back walking
like my old self again hopefully not
falling off of the patio anymore
yeah hopefully I'm okay by summerama
great Segway great segue I have just a
few announcements and one of them is
summerama
yay it's coming up in August it's for
all of our kiddos entering kindergarten
and those have gone up through sixth
grade all of you kiddos are welcome at
summerama uh so we need you guys to sign
up so if you're a kid ask your parent to
sign you up and if you are a teenager or
a parent or someone who just loves
spending time with kids we would love to
have you volunteer it's super super fun
and in order to register or to sign up
to volunteer you can do that on our
website there are links right on our
home page we also have a QR code there's
one of those in the back of this room
and also in the little table out there
just scan it with your phone and that'll
take you directly to those sign up forms
to either register your kiddo or to
volunteer to be a part of that so please
do that as soon as possible so that our
kids ministry volunteers and leaders
know how many to plan for it's really
helpful for that so don't forget about
summerama it's a great time it is that
first Friday and Saturday in August so
it's coming up pretty quickly
secondly uh July July is the time here
at the table where we downshift a bit
take the the foot off the gas so to
speak and we remember that God is God
and we are not and so Brett takes the
month off of preaching just to rest and
refresh it's a preventative thing so
that he doesn't get burned out it's a
really really good rest Rhythm it's also
biblical you know God took the seventh
day off as a Sabbath we like to do that
around there around here too so most of
our Meetup leaders are taking some of
the month off if not all you'll notice
we don't have as many people in
attendance and rest is good rest is good
and it also gives us a chance to hear
from some great speakers in our own
Community we've heard from Lori Miriam
we'll have Jesse tonight and then we'll
have Christian and Megan gray hearing
next week and then yep it is we love
Jesse and then Brett will return that
first Sunday in August so how about if
we take some time to downshift ourselves
tonight
just take a breath whatever it is that
helps you to feel centered
maybe it's listening to your own
heartbeat maybe it's closing your eyes
maybe it's thinking about something or
someone that brings you Joy or peace or
love
and just rest there for a moment
God thank you for tonight thank you for
those who are here with us those who are
watching online and for those that
weren't able to make it tonight God I
pray your blessings over each one of
them may each one of them know how loved
they are and
um
how close you are to each one of them
God help us to feel your presence
tonight to feel your love and to rest in
that tonight God in Jesus name we pray
amen
amen thank you Karen will you guys go
ahead and stand with us we're going to
get started and if you are new around
here I just wanted to take a second to
introduce ourselves and this is Josh and
Joe Brock
in the front here tell them the couple
names oh and we were talking about
couple names earlier so guess what Josh
and Joe Brock's couple name is Josh
um or Josh however you would like to
pronounce it is totally fine so
and this is Caitlin and I'm Mindy and
and that's my girl
since it seems that we're all claiming
parents tonight and claiming children so
um so yeah we're we're glad to be
together and to have some space worship
is for me the opportunity to enter into
a creative space together and allow God
to be present with us and
um it's always amazing to me how he uses
music to touch some very like sacred
places in our life and sometimes some
vulnerable places so I hope that you
feel the freedom to let him into some of
those spaces with us because we want to
approach this as a team up here we want
to approach it as a Connecting Point
where we can be vulnerable and authentic
and these songs are hopefully just as
true for us as they would be for you so
um so enter in with us in that if you're
able to and Josh is going to get us
started
[Music]
thank you
I lose my ability
to be afraid when I see the way you love
me
and draw the fear that held my
feet to the floor
it don't hold me anymore
[Music]
when I see your face
Everything Changes in the
radiance of your smile
[Music]
I got this way of
chasing away those
[Music]
Shadows that hang around
Lord I fall down again
I'm finding out just who I am
[Music]
it's all the voices
Everything Changes enough
radiant severe smile
[Music]
got this away
chasing away those
Shadows that hang around
again
just who I am
Lord I fall down again
I'm finding out just who I am
[Music]
goodbye
hopelessness and pain
[Music]
who has come the old is washed away
with all my days
[Music]
I believe I'll never be the same
see your face
Everything Changes in the
radius of your smile
got this away
chasing away those
Shadows that hang around
through it
when I see your face
Everything Changes in the
radiance of your smile
got this
chasing away those
Shadows that hang around
I'm fine
just who I am
[Music]
Lord I fall down again
I'm finding out just who I am
I'm finding out just to I am
joy and hello truth hello love I've
longed for you
I've waited for this moment
all my days
right thanks guys
um kiddos y'all are dismissed and
tonight our little kiddos are going to
go back there a little change up
so you can follow Brittany that
direction
and a big thank you to
um Abby and Whitney and Elle and August
and Angie anyone else who's helping out
with our kids tonight we appreciate it
um we have a lot of them here and Lord
knows we are so so grateful for our kids
team they are such a blessing to us
um
I uh just wanted to share as we're kind
of moving into the rest of our set we're
about to go into prayers of the people
and Caitlyn's actually going to lead
that
um for us tonight but I just wanted to
say tonight I'm coming in with like a
really heavy heart um there's a girl
that I coach and a friend of my daughter
who is losing her mom a 13 year old girl
and basically had six weeks to find out
she was sick and now she's waiting to
take her final breath and my heart has
just been broken this week just how what
do you say to a 13 year old girl what I
mean what are the words you know that
can heal something like that and
um and so there's just been a lot of
crying a lot of Tears a lot of
processing and you know you put yourself
in that Mom's position and just all the
hopes and the dreams that you would have
for your child you know who's going to
be there without you and
um
in all of that my prayer is just like
you know sometimes just the honesty of
saying I don't even know what to pray
right now I don't even have words that
could help the situation so just
trusting that God knows what the need is
and that he's going to be close and
sometimes that's all I can say is like
God Jesus be close like Jesus be close
and it's like a mantra that's just been
on my lips
as I've just been waiting you know as
the news has unfolded and tonight if
there's something that you're carrying
that is heavy that you just don't have
words for that just doesn't seem like
there are any prayers left to pray I
just want to encourage you that he's
with us even in that and he knows that
he's there holding our hearts that he's
there ready to comfort ready to walk
beside us so um yeah I just I just
wanted to share that invulnerability to
say sometimes it's like why even pray
I've said all the prayers there's
nothing left but I believe that even in
those moments just opening ourselves up
to God's spirit sometimes he meets us in
a really beautiful way
um so Caitlyn can you go ahead and lead
us in that tonight
you'll pray this aloud with us
if I sound like I'm crying I'm sorry
I'm sorry for this city of Sachse Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and will to conserve it
we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health
we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
hips
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and light healing and Hope peace
and a deep sense of your presence amen
thank you
[Music]
you give thy
you are loved
you bring light to the darkness
[Music]
you restore
every heart that is broken
great are you Lord
it's your breath in our lungs so we pour
out our place pour out our praise it's
your bread in our lungs
so we pour out our praise to you only
[Music]
you give life you are love you bring
light to the darkness you give hope
you restore
every heart that is broken
[Music]
back
below
[Music]
this song is just really getting me
right now my one of my best friends was
just diagnosed with cancer
second time so
spare with me sing out loud so that I'm
not feeling alone up here
[Music]
all the Earth Will shout your praise our
hearts will cry these bones will sing
Grace
[Music]
our hearts will cry these bones will
sing
great
[Music]
all the Earth will shout your praise our
hearts will cry these bones will sing
[Music]
it's your brain in our lungs
in our lungs
so we pour out our praise to you only
it's your breath
in our lungs
so we pour out a praise
it's your bread
in our lungs
[Music]
you won't be
Jesus thank you for holding us
for being a sustainer god
and one who goes with us
even into the darkness
you are worthy you are good
and you're present
worthy of every song we could ever sing
worthy of
the praise
[Music]
Jesus the name above every other name
this is the only one who could ever say
worthy of every breath we could ever
breathe we live for you
[Music]
and holy there is no one like you there
is none beside you open up my eyes
[Music]
thank you
worthy of every song we could ever see
worthy of all the praise
[Music]
Jesus the only one who could ever say
we live for you
[Music]
and holy there is no one like you there
is none beside you open up my eyes
[Music]
around
my life
of it is a firm foundation
and I will put my trust
in you alone
and I will never be sing that with us I
will build
[Music]
my life
it is
[Music]
and I will not be shaken
my life
[Music]
like you there is none beside you open
up my eyes
[Music]
Lead Me
Jesus we build our lives upon the rock
of Your Love
trusting that you are enough
trusting that you will have the final
say
that you are a redeeming God and a
healing God and a Waymaker
and that when our lives fall apart that
you are the one who puts us back
together that you are the one who has
known our story from the beginning
that you are the one who has loved us
with an everlasting love
thank you for your presence
for your constant love
your constant Pursuit
your constant Grace
God we lean on him we anchor ourselves
into it
and we look to you God to show us a Way
Forward
to lead us in your love to those around
us
and it's in your name that we pray and
have asked all these things
amen
thank you guys for supporting us as we
all kind of make our way through this
set after a hard week
um if you would turn to the people
around you just say hello greet someone
and then Jessie's Gonna Get Us started
all right are you all already done
greeting each other already
well thank you friends up here part of
the worship team you know one of the
things that we
um
our core values here are incredibly
important to us right and so that
authenticity and that inclusivity in
ways uh you just saw it lived out on
stage here is incredible authenticity
but also inclusivity in the way that
anyone who is broken is still welcome
like it does not matter what you're
going through in your life
you still have a seat at the table and
not every church is like that
um I've been to several that would not
have welcomed that kind of uh
authenticity from the stage and so I'm
very proud to call these people my
friends and get to be a part of this
community
um
July is a great month does anyone know
why
and why because Brett is gone and we all
needed we needed that didn't we
we needed that we needed that break it's
like when dad leaves for the weekend you
get to throw a rager you know
um so welcome to the rager yeah
um no but truly I love July um because
for for one you know we get to be
reminded that God does not just only
speak through our pastor
um but that God speaks through us as a
community and so we get to hear from
several different people and different
voices and it is it is a beautiful
reminder it's it's good to hear from the
other people in our community and so
last July I was up here almost a year
ago to the day I was up here preaching a
message titled the reality of Hope
and at that point I was going through a
ridiculous amount of things like it was
I was going through some very heavy
things I felt very raw and I basically
got up here and just publicly processed
things that God was saying to me about
all the junk I was going through right
was anybody here for that cool oh cool
cool
um so I am happy to report that I am
still going through heavy things and
still feels kind of raw
um so today I'm going to preach a
message titled the reality of peace and
so I've decided that this is just going
to be a series and I'm going to preach
one every July for the next six years
and it's going to be the longest series
ever it's gonna be great
um so so like I mentioned last July I
was going through a lot and that kind of
continued into the fall
um I had just started as my first year
as a special education teacher at a
large elementary school and I had to
switch careers very quickly and so I
jumped into education which is widely
known as one of the easiest things you
could do
um and so I jumped into it was a joke
everyone knows it's not
um but I jumped into it and it was
extremely hard like I knew it was going
to be hard but I had no idea like what
level of challenging it was going to be
because I had I was having to learn
everything fresh because I didn't go to
school for this so I was like drinking
from a fire hose all of these like laws
and rules and paperwork and teaching and
children all these things and then
having to do it at the same time so I
was learning and then doing and learning
and then doing so by the time Christmas
break rolled around I was kind of done
already I was burnt out it was really
hard I was tired and then on my way home
from Christmas Eve service my car broke
down
and then on the 27th of December I got
it towed away and y'all I'm I still
haven't seen it
um it like it's still like I've been in
this weird car process it's been so I
had to pay for a rental out of pocket I
had to like get a lawyer all it's just
it's been a mess it's been an absolute
mess Plus at that time one of my
students from school had like just lost
his father and he was visually impaired
a third grader the quadruplets lose
their father just instantly one week and
so we're there was just a lot going on
in my life
around February it was just like all
happening at once incredibly
overwhelming and I I just I didn't know
how to handle that amount of things
happening at once because usually like
you can have one bad thing happen at a
time and you can kind of like weather it
and be like oh one at a time but that's
not usually how life works right like
the whole when it rains it pours like I
hate that because it's true
um it was just a lot of things all at
once and so I was out of training at Cox
Elementary just up the road from here
and I had my son with me and I had
rushed from my school to to Cox
Elementary I ran in and Justice was with
me and they're presenting this
information and I just like suddenly I
just start to feel weird like I was just
feeling weird like my chest started to
get tight I started to feel nauseous I
was having a hard time breathing and
like I I was kind of like paralyzed
because and the feelings kept getting
worse and worse and worse and I knew
something was wrong when Justice looked
up to me he's like Dad you you don't
look okay are you okay do we need to
leave and having had one before I knew
that I was on the verge of a panic
attack and I had only had one really bad
one before in my life but this I'm like
this one's gonna be really bad and so I
grabbed him I threw all my stuff in my
bag and we book it out of there just
barely make it to the car before I lost
it
I lost it and I could tell like I don't
know if if any of you have had panic
attacks to that level like they're they
are alarming they're fierce and scary
for a for an eight-year-old who's
watching their dad go through this in
the car like which made me feel even
worse about the situation and so at that
moment it started that day that they I
realized it became the slow and painful
realization that I was experiencing some
very potent inner dissonance in my life
like my inner world was in shambles I
was not okay and to not be okay in my
world is not okay like everyone says
it's okay to not be okay and I'm fine
saying that for other people
but for me to not be okay it's not okay
because I'm a Christian
right I'm supposed I'm supposed to be
okay like Christians have the fruit of
the spirit right in one of those fruits
of the spirit is peace
and so here I am I I have hit this spot
where I I was raised in evangelicalism
I was raised in evangelicalism so I I
had I had
um I had gotten this idea this this
ideal Christian built up in my head
right
this this this Christian is this person
is well put together nothing phases them
they exude love joy peace patience
kindness gentleness and self-control
they are completely unaffected by
negative emotions or circumstances and
they have really good credit like they
okay
Maybe not maybe not that one or maybe I
don't know
um but but but they were in my mind
they're pure Christ likeness like they
are a perfect mirroring of who Christ is
which is perfection this is how I viewed
the the ideal Christian and you guys I
am so so far away from that ideal
so far away from that ideal
so I found myself in this strange place
of being completely full of anxiety
stress
and also claiming to be a Christian who
shouldn't feel those things all the time
and
peace felt unrealistic to me
at that point
in fact and I know that a lot of people
feel this I mean even just from the
things that are being shared this
evening
there is a lot of heavy a lot of heavy
and there was recently and just in 2022
the Barnard group did a a study where
they
um did a survey of thousands and
thousands of adults and teens asking
them what is the primary thing they want
from their spiritual life their their
faith walk and the number one thing
overwhelming percentage was inner peace
so people we want this desperately
but peace feels unrealistic
feels unrealistic in the midst of
uncertainty and hardship
of our daily lives which is a lot all
the time
however I think the reason peace feels
unrealistic is that we have a tainted
view of what peace is supposed to look
like
right what peace is supposed to look
like in our daily lives and a lot of
that is due to the people and how they
have portrayed peace to us and if you
grew up in the church like me the other
side of that is the verses that have
been quoted to you for your whole life
and how that has portrayed peace to you
and so what we're going to do today is
we're going to look at one of those
verses that was quoted at me all the
time throughout my life and kind of
created this tainted view of Peace in my
mind so we're going to be in Philippians
uh Chapter 4 verses four through seven
it should be up here if you want to
follow along
but we're here we go
rejoice in the lord always I will say it
again rejoice
let your gentleness be evident to all
the Lord is near do not be anxious about
anything but in every situation by
prayer and petition with Thanksgiving
present your request to God and the
peace of God
which transcends all understanding will
guard your hearts and your minds in
Christ Jesus beautiful verse
no
beautiful
it wasn't to me most of the time because
here's the thing that this little piece
of scripture is plucked out of a larger
letter
that was written from Paul we we like
Paul right I don't
um was written from Paul to a tiny
little church in Philippi it's a very
small Church a very personal little
letter that of of people that he had
gotten close to and so he he writes this
letter
and and this is why I just I have this
contentious relationship with Paul and
his letters because people just pluck
out one little verse from one of his
letters and say boom
their verse for example you know maybe
I'm feeling like one time I'd be feeling
anxious or stressed at church and I
would come up to somebody and like need
to talk or they notice that I'm anxious
and they're like what's wrong or like
what's wrong my son and I'm just like
I'm
stressed I feel anxious and they're like
well you know what Paul says
don't be anxious
it's so frustrating that's like me
saying I feel anxious and somebody's
saying have you tried not being anxious
I never thought of that like it feels
silly to me the way people use verses
like this to do those kinds of things
because that is not what's happening in
the grand letter the the way people use
that is not what's happening in the
letter right it is gross to me
infuriating how people use these verses
but I think if Paul were alive today
and he heard how people used the words
from his letters to his friends
he would probably be horrified he would
probably be horrified he'd be like wow
that's in the Bible like you put all my
letters wow
it's it's weird if you think about it
like
um for one this is like a personal
letter that he wrote from prison to a
small group of people he's not thinking
millions of people are going to read
this
no this is to a very specific group of
people
and here we have it like can you oh for
what can you imagine us doing that with
one of your emails
think about there's an email that you
write to a friend or to a family member
we just pluck it out and say this is in
the Bible now
millions of people are going to read
this email
like this is strange this is strange
that but here here it is and this is a
part of our sacred text this little
letter
I just I I have to name that that this
is not this is weird that we do this
this is strange
and we have to take into consideration
that we know very very little about the
people that Paul is writing to we know a
little bit but it's little it's very
little
and what but what we do know is that
Paul is in prison right because Paul was
really good at getting himself thrown
into prison really good at it and so he
was in Philippi and they were
experiencing intense persecution as a
little Community to the point where Paul
is falsely accused of something he gets
arrested and he is forced to flee out of
that place and this tiny little church
in Philippi inherited all of that
persecution that he he left and he
leaves this town and they get it all and
so they're experiencing this not only
that but there's this major fight
happening between two women in their
community that is like dividing the
church
and they have these false teachers
trying to pull them off the path of
following Christ there is a lot going on
in this little church
and that is what Paul is trying to
encourage and that's it's in that
context that he is writing rejoice in
the lord always I will say it again
rejoice
in the peace of God which transcends all
understanding will guard your hearts you
see how different that is it just feels
different because it wasn't written to
you or me it was written to this little
group of people who were really going
through it and you can imagine how
anxious this community must have been in
the midst of all that and you got to
realize when they're experiencing
persecution it's not like like a thumbs
down on a verse on Facebook like
not that no like
fear for your life persecution
so their anxiety is on a whole nother
level in this in this place
but and I can also imagine so when Paul
tells them have peace I'm sure they're
like
what
have peace Rejoice I'm sure that they
are weary
extremely weary
when I was learning how to drive when I
was a young lad
um many years ago I was I was very
nervous to learn how to drive because I
had to learn to drive on a stick how
many of you learned to drive on a stick
wow yes none of you children nope nope
none of y'all it's more and more rare
right and not to mention my parents were
divorced so I had three adults who were
going to teach me how to drive my mother
my father and my stepmother and I can
tell you that these three people could
not be more different in their
philosophies of driving instruction
completely different people so my mom
you know she's teaching me in her little
white Subaru in Colorado you know in my
church parking lot and she's very kind
very very very patient but you know when
like if you don't do the gas in time you
start it's I called the death Lurch it's
like and my mom's just like
it's okay it's okay she like speaks very
kindly to me never yelled never got
angry it's beautiful
um my dad on the other hand would take
me in his Jeep behind a grocery store
and he would be like hey he would make
me recite all the rules he would make me
he would make me do every step to to his
liking and he would make me drive
extremely slow like extremely slow and
it was painful for me because I'm like I
just like I want to go and he's like no
no
what about the stick is it in the
correct gear you know like very very
very chill but then there's my stepmom
a very intense personality she
introduced me to Led Zeppelin in
weightlifting
and and was like as an entrepreneur and
like starts all these businesses just
like
power person and so she takes me behind
the same grocery store but she's not
wearing her seatbelt because why that
live life on the edge I about put her
through the windshield her head hits the
windshield when I slam on the brakes it
was bad guys it was bad so all three of
them very different but there was one
thing that I did that all three of them
would always comment on and that was
anytime I got more nervous or more
focused I would grip the wheel really
really hard does anyone else do this I
call it the death grip like you just
grip it really hard and I don't know
what it was like my body thought if I
just grip the wheel hard enough you know
I will you know drive better or have
more control or something and I always
drove worse with this like it just made
me more nervous more anxious all this
stuff I share this story because I
believe this is one way we can just
describe our tainted view of peace
you know in our modern day Society
especially America even more especially
in the Dallas area peace has a certain
vibe
peace has a maybe even a flavor it's
it's a nice house and a nice part of
town
maybe it's a nice vehicle even a Tesla
maybe maybe it's maybe it's well-behaved
kids who play Club Level Sports
maybe it's a really nice salary like and
mind you like this is all the stuff that
brings people peace right yeah we can
all agree that this stuff brings people
peace
no no you're not there with me
there are a lot of people who would say
yes
a lot of people who would say yes and
the pro and hear me those things in and
of themselves are not bad things if
somebody were to offer me a Tesla right
now I'd say sure great
those things aren't bad but when those
things
equal
peace
when security and certainty equal peace
we are in trouble
we're in trouble
we're in real trouble like in another
example is when peace equals how well
you are liked or respected by your
colleagues or your family or your
friends like the moment like you start
having conflict with people like your
piece just leaves and then you start
like manipulating people to get them to
like you more or to give you a raise or
to do whatever and it's just a mess
if we believe
if we believe that peace is a work of
the will
if we think peace is something we can
produce we're missing it
we're missing it
and you guys like these things is like a
death grip on the Wheel of Life we just
think if I can just hold on tighter I
can get peace if I if I just like hold
on tighter I can get control of my life
if I just hold on tighter I can get my
stuff together
and get the peace that I long for
but it is
it is a facade of control
we hold on tighter because we think we
somehow are in control that we can make
it happen
Thomas Merton uh my my spiritual
forefather
um he would say it this way and before I
read this forgive his gendered language
he is from a different time if he was
alive today he would not write like this
I am certain of it
and it's a long quote so stay with me
he says this peace however is not to be
obtained by brute force and by the
violent despotic suppression of our
appetites
peace is not the work of force but the
fruit of love
the love and love means submission to
Christ docile's objection to his Spirit
true peace is the work of God's mercy
and not of man's will
when we yield ourselves to him in love
his presence itself appeases our desires
and quiets our rebellious passions and
if at times there are storms in our
hearts if God appears to be sleeping we
can still have deep peace in the midst
of conflict if we really trust him
peace is not a work of the will but a
gift of God
it is not some we cannot simply
produce peace or will it into existence
and this is where we get to to see the
true meaning of the phrase peace that
transcends all understanding how many of
you have said this and just like I don't
even know what that means I I I say all
the time like what what does that mean
but this is what it means
Paul is speaking about peace as a
response
different than anxiety so as a sped
teacher I get this cool little perk and
that is I get to know when the fire
drills are happening before they happen
it's great they will they will call me
and say hey in about 10 minutes fire
drill so I get to tell a few of my
students who cannot handle it you know
they just can't handle they can't handle
it so I'll sit I'll sit them down and
and I'll say hey in about 10 minutes
we are going to have a fire drill and
they get nervous I say but everything's
okay it's not real we will quietly get
up from our seat walk over to the door
and walk outside
do you understand yes Mr Watts I
understand
do you understand how we're going to do
it yes are you going to be concerned or
afraid when this happens no I'll be fine
five minutes later it happens
and they start running around the room
the same kind of like what oh we just
had this conversation we just had this
conversation but honestly I can't blame
him because it's a fire alarm they are
alarming
they are alarming the the situation that
is an expected response to an alarm
going off right and we all have these
situations in our lives
that would warrant an anxious response
where an anxious response would be
expected even
but what but what sets us apart
what sets us apart and what Paul is
getting at here is that when the storms
of life rage around us and the normal
and expected response is anxiety that we
would respond with peace
that peace that transcends understanding
peace that does not make any sense so in
the situations where anxiety is the norm
what sets us apart is that we're not
going to do the norm we are going to be
different and peaceful now I know what
you're thinking and I can see it on some
of y'all's face Jesse aren't you just
saying to stop being anxious and be
peaceful instead
no
I'm not because I wholeheartedly
understand the anxiety and stress do not
disappear overnight for people and in
fact some people will have some level of
that their whole lives like it's it's
present it's present
and so what I what I think what I think
though is that like
anxiety and stress will be there but
what can lessen over time is our anxious
reactions to things
does that make sense do you see the the
difference there what and and even more
importantly the Deep reality of Peace
can be present even in the midst of
anxiety and hardship but that kind of
Peace cannot be bought that kind of
peace takes time it's a journey because
peace is not a product it is a process
it is not something you can just buy and
suddenly have
it's a process
it's a process and we receive and
experience this piece as an outgrowth of
an intimate relationship with God it's
very much like me learning to drive and
learning to loosen my grip on the wheel
like I still catch myself doing this
but over time I learned to loosen my
grip on the wheel to the point where now
most of the time loose grip
where it was the opposite most of the
time death grip and then loose grip a
little bit of the time
the reality of peace is that it isn't a
work of our will but a loosening of our
death grip on the wheel of Our Lives
we're just loosening our death grip even
just a little bit but how how on Earth
are we supposed to learn to loosen our
death grip on life well Paul makes this
very clear on how to not be anxious he
tells us exactly what to do he says this
in verse six do not be anxious about
anything but in every situation by
prayer and petition with Thanksgiving
present your request to God and the
peace of God which transcends all
understanding will guard your hearts and
your minds in Christ Jesus it feels
overly simplistic
but the answer is prayer
the answer is prayer and I can feel the
eye rolls whether physically or
spiritually I can feel them because I
know how frustrating it can feel when
you're going through something serious
and somebody says just pray about it
just pray about it most of the people
who are just who are saying just pray
about it they're not actually wanting
you inviting you into a prayer life
they're they're using that as a
throwaway phrase to deflect your pain
because it's too hard for them
they're like yeah just pray about it
but I I am standing here to tell you as
one who's been through a lot recently in
the recent years that the kind of prayer
that Paul is suggesting here in his
letter does bring peace
even if it's in small amounts
you know I first experienced this in a
prayer practice called the prayer of
relinquishment
um I I want to share this practice with
you and I know I'm running way long here
but I want to share this with you
because it's been so vital for me um
this prayer mirrors Jesus in The Garden
of Gethsemane if you remember in the
gospel story he's in the garden he's
extremely anxious and stressed like in
some some have interpreted and some
scriptures say like he was so stressed
he was sweating blood like that level
cool that Jesus also has anxiety
problems too right like he was human
just like us and he comes to God and he
prays this prayer my father if it is not
possible for this cup to be taken away
unless I drink it may your will be done
he tried to get out of the crucifixion
he was so scared
terrified
that blows my mind
and this is what this prayer
is so for for instance an example
last night I I'm I'm praying to God and
what I'll do is you you present your
request just like Paul says and then at
the end of it you say yet not my will
but yours be done and you do this over
and over and over again it's the last
time I'm like oh God I'm so nervous to
preach like why I've done this a
thousand times I'm still like freaking
out about this every single time I just
wanted to go well I just wanted to be
meaningful I just want to not stutter
yet not my will but yours be done
and then I would another thing that I'm
anxious about do it over again I do it
over and over and over again and last
night I actually tried something new
where I I squeeze my hands really tight
the death grip really tight as I'm
requesting something God I I'm scared to
go into the the school year I my friends
all switched schools like I don't I
don't want to do this
yet not my will but yours be done
and as I do this over and over again
I can feel the death grip loosening
in my heart over and over and over again
and you know what I do I do feel peace
but it is a practice it is that it's a
practice it must be practiced and
through that practice eventually that
peace that surpasses understanding will
begin to guard your heart where your
your peaceful responses
will be more than your anxious responses
the the amount of time you spend in
prayer with God this way that kind of
prayer that peace that you will get from
that will guard your heart from the
things that normally will give an
anxious response
I I've experienced it it sounds crazy
but I have experienced it in my life
so this is my encouragement to you
the reality of peace is that it is not a
work of our will it is not something
that we can make happen but it is a
loosening of our of our death grip on
our lives
trusting in the immeasurable depth of
God's love for you
we do this through a life of Prayer in
connection to God who always listens
loves and graciously gives
so now as we come to the table
let us remember that it is Jesus the
prince of peace who was crucified on the
cross buried in the grave and on the
third day rose from the dead claiming
Eternal victory over darkness and death
it is because of this good news that we
take these elements and Proclaim Christ
as the way the truth and the life
so what we do here is we practice what's
called an open table that means anybody
here is welcome to take communion with
us that it does not matter where you've
been what you've done what you think of
yourself what others think of you you
are welcome to come to the table and
take this
the bread is gluten-free
there are there are two colors the white
is grape juice and the red is the real
deal wine
so let's do this this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
it is made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed
come because it is the Lord who invites
you it is his will that those who want
him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
foreign
relax
at your name
still call the sweetest
the Raging me to still every
ways at your name
Jesus Jesus
you will make the darkness tremble Jesus
Jesus
silence fear
Jesus Jesus
you make the darkness tremble Jesus
Jesus
breathe call these Loans To Live
call these lungs to sing once again
I will Praise
Jesus Jesus
you make the darkness tremble Jesus
Jesus
Jesus Jesus
make the darkness tremble Jesus Jesus
let's sing your name
your name is a light that the Shadows
can deny your name cannot be
overcome
your name is alive
forever lifted High
your name cannot be overcome can you
guys stand and sing that with us your
name is a light that the Shadows can't
deny
your name cannot be overcome
[Music]
your name cannot be overcome let's sing
Jesus oh Jesus Jesus
you make the darkness tremble Jesus
Jesus
silence fear Jesus Jesus
you make the darkness
Jesus
[Music]
sing it again
Jesus Jesus
you make the darkness tremble Jesus
Jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
Jesus Jesus Jesus
thanks so much for being here tonight
um I hope it blessed you in some way
hit you right where you are reminded you
that you're not alone and whatever
you're going through Jesse thank you for
that I hope we don't have to wait
another year to hear from you but I am
looking forward to the next four year
installment of your series
um if you need prayer somebody to talk
to or just a hug come find me after
service I would love to be there for you
also don't forget about summerama sign
up your kids sign up to volunteer you
can find all that information at
thetabletx.org
also if you're visiting with us tonight
we have cards out on the little tiny
table in the hallway if you wouldn't
mind filling out one of those drop it in
the box that way we have a record that
you are here we can just thank you for
that
um
lastly I would like to send you all off
into your week with the spin addiction
this blessing that I believe is true for
each and every one of you here and each
and every one of you who are watching
online
uh you can feel free to put out your
hands in a posture of receiving or just
open your heart to these words
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
love and compassion and Grace to
everyone you come in contact with this
week
have a good night be blessed we hope to
see you back here next Sunday good night
[Music]
your name is a light that the Shadows
can't deny your name
cannot be overcome
[Music]
your name is
your name
is
[Music]
cannot be overcome
oh Jesus Jesus
you made the darkness tremble Jesus
Jesus
Jesus Jesus
you make the darkness tremble Jesus
Jesus
eyes
[Music]